so it looks like Aquaman and the lost
kingdom might suffer the same fate that
the flash did I hope it's not true I
hope it does well but in a recent
article published by variety the studio
and the movie are dealing with so much
drama right now and had been through the
entirety of the filming process for
example one thing it says is that Jason
Mamoa would dress up on set as Johnny
Depp on set reportedly drunk to
supposedly harass Amber herd but this is
coming from Amber herd it's actually
coming from documents released by her
therapist so this is what amber herd
said this article is filled with a lot
including what some people have said
about the recent test screenings for
Aquaman 2 and it doesn't sound too good
unfortunately and it's a shame because
this is really the last film from the SN
verse basically after this film James
gun's new DCU is going to take effect
and we're not 100% sure how the new DCU
is going to be but pretty much the SN
verse is going to pretty much be gone
after this film so it's a shame that so
much drama had to be attached to this
film now obviously due to the Amber herd
and Johnny Depp case their trial
everything people had eyes on Aquaman 2
wondering what was going to be happening
with Amber herd's role of mea were they
going to fire her were they going to
recast her they did this for Johnny Depp
in some movies and according to this
article at one point in time after the
first Aquaman movie was released they
were going to fire Amber herd but her
boy at the time Elon Musk wrote a letter
to Warner Brothers what this article
calls a quote scorched Earth letter to
Warner Brothers threatening to burn the
house down end quote so a lot to dive
into including like I mentioned
reactions to test grings of Aquaman 2
that the studio has been doing recently
so let's dive into this article and talk
about what all it says about what has
been going on with Aquaman 2 and if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos and if you subscribe and leave a
comment you're automatically entered in
our giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
and some DC items as well the winner
gets to pick one item and we pick a
winner at the end of each month so
clearly a lot of drama attached to the
movie but unfortunately it looks like
the movie itself isn't screening too
high variety said this in one of their
paragraphs still the Aquaman sequel held
promise considering that the character's
first outing earned
1.15 billion worldwide becoming the
highest grossing DC movie ever but
sources say the sequel has endured
challenges outside of the herd Saga and
was testing in the 60s before being
recut in the summer of 2022 despite the
overhaul the film continued to test in
the 60s prompting a new Cut quote the
movie is like this echo of regimes end
quote says one Insider another quote
says it's The Last Remnant of the SN
verse and no one really wants to take
ownership of it end quote the paragraph
then Ends by stating re-shoot took place
right up until this year's WG GA strike
in May the onset Source disputes the
idea that Aquaman 2 is troubled noting
that the film was on time under budget
and needed only about a week of re-shoot
so that's good news but you'll find that
in this article they State multiple
conflicting reports However the fact
that the movie was testing in the 60s
before the recut and then still testing
in the 60s after the recut is not great
news now the trailer does look pretty
good and there is definitely hope for
this movie but the fact that it's been
testing in the 60s D D minus D+ range
isn't great news plus it has the herd
drama attached to it and we know how
that affected the flash there were a lot
of people out there that didn't go see
the flash because of Ezra Miller and his
past however one thing Aquaman 2 has
going for it that the flash didn't have
going for it is that the main character
the main actor isn't the problem amber
herd is not the main character of
Aquaman 2 and from what we've heard
she's pretty much been sidelined a great
deal in fact in the trailer we only
really saw her once for a very brief
time so Jason Mamoa can go out there and
promote the film a lot and a lot of
people really do like and love Jason
Mamoa so that's good Ezra Miller could
not promote the flash so at least
Aquaman 2 has that going for them but
apparently there really was a lot of
drama on set and a lot more drama came
out when they actually released the
first trailer for the film variety
states on the same day in mid-september
that Warner Bros dropped the trailer for
its 215 million Aquaman in the lost
kingdom embarrassing documents from the
Johnny Depp Amber herd defamation trial
surfaced on Reddit creating a new
headache for the studio behind the film
Depp fans paid the court fees for the
release of documents from herd's
therapists Dr Don Hughes the raw notes
scribbled on a legal pad were part of
last year's high-profile trial in which
debt largely prevailed and this is where
it gets pretty crazy it says they
describe a hostile Aquaman set to wear
an allegedly intoxicated Jason mimoa
dressed like Depp and pushed to have
herd booted from the role of Aquaman
superhero Mira now keep in mind this is
something that Amber herd was telling
her therapist that her therapist wrote
down so it is literally just the word of
Amber herd so that does not make this
factual by any means especially since
we've seen a lot of the stuff Amber herd
has said in trial but the notes say
Jason said he wanted me fired Jason
drunk late on set dressing like Johnny
has all the Rings too I'm assuming she
is speaking of all the rings that Johnny
Depp typically wears but here's where
the reports get conflicting a rep for
Jason Mamoa declined to comment but a DC
spokesperson pushed back on herd's
characterization of Jason Mamoa saying
Jason Mamoa conducted himself in a
professional manner at all times on the
set of Aquaman and the lost kingdom
which sounds like Jason Mamoa plus if
Jason mimoa was on set dressing as
Johnny Depp trying to get Amber herd
fired that would have probably gotten
out a long time ago Studios can't keep
stuff like that a secret there's tons of
people on set and as we know Leaks get
out all the time especially with Warner
Brothers in DC so I feel like we would
have definitely heard about that before
if it actually happened because somebody
would have talked about it others stated
and I quote Jason works his butt off
likes to have a beer once in a while
like everyone but doesn't show up drunk
to set and variety said that this is
said by an Insider who was on the London
set in 2021 and the ins also said that
the two stars got along and were seen
joking together and ended it by stating
he isn't dressing like Johnny Deb he has
always dressed in that Bohemian style
which I would definitely agree with
variety reached out to Amber herd and
she declined to comment unfortunately
the therapy session notes also had James
Juan the director's name in there as
well the note says he raised his voice
at me I can't even post about Aquaman
made it like it was my fault I said I'm
sorry nobody could take selfies with me
on set given blackout James ju declined
to comment about this but the DC
spokesperson says James Juan is known
for treating members of his cast and
crew with the utmost respect and for
fostering a positive collaborative
environment on set the Aquaman films
were no exception basically stating he
always treats everybody with respect but
here's the kicker like I mentioned in
the beginning there was something with
Elon Musk that happened after the first
Aquaman the article States and yet herd
was nearly fired sources on both sides
tell variety so on Amber herd's side and
on DC's side it states following
Aquaman's release in 2018 the studio in
Juan decided to drop the actress from
the sequel due to her lack of chemistry
with Jason Mamoa and sent a letter to
her attorney those sources uncore that
the move to bounce herd was unrelated to
Depp and took place before he filed suit
against the actress in 2019 likewise
Mima was not involved in the decision-
making they end by stating ultimately
the studio never pulled the trigger
uniring herd because of her former
boyfriend Elon Musk had one of his
litigators sent a scorched Earth letter
to Warner Brothers threatening to burn
the house down if the actress wasn't
brought back for a sequel says a source
familiar with the behind the-scenes
battle Warner Bros caved and moved
forward with herd and variety states
that Elon Musk did not respond to a
request for a comment so a lot of drama
is surrounding this movie unfortunately
and it makes it even worse if this is
true and they really didn't want am
heard back for the second film anyways
and then the trial came out making it
even worse hopefully there is hope for
Aquaman 2 hopefully Jason Mamoa can get
out there and promote the heck out of it
and hopefully the story is good and
hopefully it's not like the flash
tarnished by things that aren't really
related to the movie fingers crossed and
in the meantime let us know are you
going to go see Aquaman 2 are you
excited for it let us know your thoughts
in the comments down below don't forget
to like the video and subscribe to stay
up to date on all the latest news you
can find us on Instagram and Twitter and
as always than thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof